by coming at you with the feels on this
one I was excited to watch this so let's
talk about it
[Music]
you can tell
whether so you get you get low energy
Jeremy today a nice change of pace so
still a Michael J fox movie is an
autobiography about Michael J Fox as
told by him that's what autobiography
means so I guess that was a little
redundant under the weather like I said
and the world is full of biographies
there are biographies out there very
fascinating looks there are also some
biographies out there I mean not all of
them but sometimes you met with that
feeling of yeah but who asked but in the
case of Michael J fox I don't know about
you but yes I I have asked for this I I
want to know all the things yes we live
in the age of information which means
you can Chronicle it all yourself you
can do your due diligence do the
research find out all the behind the
scenes things but it's nice to have it
concisely Consolidated in one very
digestible 90 minute film also these are
his words about him from him it's not
someone else talking about Michael J fox
is there some information in here I was
like I had heard that but hearing him
actually be like yep that's how it was
it just hits different and yeah this
covers his child Hood to now and in his
life as it is today and how he deals
with his day-to-day and what I liked
about the childhood element and in a
situation like this usually it's when
you talk about the childhood and how
that feeds into the Ambitions the hopes
the dreams and where the person is today
right that's usually how it goes down
but him talking about how he was a
little kid who could never sit still he
always had to be moving and that's just
who he was he was always a very
energetic person that feeds into him
feeling like well I can't do those
things now that hits hard and that's a
huge element in this peak behind the
curtain about how his body no longer
supports his want to connect with people
on a comedic level at covering his
struggling actor phase I I find that
stuff fascinating just business-wise
there's a business Hollywood element in
here that it's engaging to me the fact
that he was selling office furniture to
make ends meet the fact that Family Ties
was supposed to be about the parents
more and he was so charismatic they were
like that's the guy and again with
information I had already heard but it's
great to hear him talk about it how he
was filming Family Ties and Back to the
Future at the same time getting about
two hours of sleep a night maybe three
if he's lucky Gotta Give It Up to the
editing in here too there are scenes
where he's talking about his past or
Studio execs were talking about him and
it'll show scenes from his movies
illustrating the vibe of that moment I
was so shocked at how well these scenes
Blended in with setting the vibe of the
situation I know actors are always
supposed to draw from something real
something they know but it's kind of
wild it feels like Michael J fox was
like all right I'm gonna take on roles
that perfectly illustrate the vibe of of
these prominent situations in my life
just in case I ever make an
autobiography about it editor needs some
can't make bricks without clay I was
baffled it was actually kind of amazing
the editing in here it's a heartfelt
look into his life his past is present
and it's also one that you're thankful
to be a part of you're thankful that
he's extended that hand to us his fans
the audience where he can be like hey
here's the story I'm gonna answer all
the questions I can
here's my life hearing from Michael J
fox himself talk about his career where
he was how he got there his Parkinson's
diagnosis and how he dealt with that
it's special and human that kind of
vulnerability and this look into his
life doesn't just deal with the past
like in his day to day every day the
struggle that is for a lot of us on the
fan side of things it was that day
Michael J fox told the world that he has
Parkinson's but for Michael J fox it's
every day is a struggle you know he's an
inspiring person it's as simple as that
this is an interesting look into the
life of an inspiring person and it's on
Apple TV right now if my Tetris review
taught me anything is that a lot of you
out there you have Apple TV so there you
go how to rate this one up how do you
even write this one up I'll say this
there was a hard copy out there it would
be worth buying on Blu-Ray so there's
that my voice cracked when I said blue
rice it's time to go now I'm gonna give
me some rest all right so still the
Michael J fox story have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more right here to
Seymour
[Music]